until about 2006 if you talk to anyone
especially real estate agents they'd
always tell you that on average
nationwide that housing always goes up
in price that you know there could be
layoffs and you know maybe oil drops off
and people have layoffs in Texas so
housing prices going on Texas or they
have layoffs in Michigan so housing
prices go down there but nationwide
housing prices do nothing could put go
up and that for the most part has been
true since the Great Depression housing
prices have been going up maybe one or
one percent or so per year actually a
little bit less and in real terms but
something fundamentally amazing happened
in the beginning part of this decade I
have right here this is the Case Shiller
index and this is probably the best
estimate of housing prices I can find
this is better than the median because
the Case Shiller actually tries to
compare the price you'd pay for the same
house and maybe we'll do another video
later on how they exactly do that but if
we look at the Case Shiller index let's
see in 2000 that's where they index it
to it
a house that costs you know a hundred
thousand dollars in two thousand or the
index was at one hundred and two
thousand by two thousand for the int
that houses nationwide this is in the
national index right here
nationwide prices had increased by forty
six percent and by 2006 where they
peaked they had increased by 88% they
had almost doubled since the price in
2000 and so the obvious question is is
why did this happen what what drove
prices to increase so fast when really
for most of the history of America
housing prices have never increased this
fast especially considering what was
happening in the broader economy and
what do I mean by that well what what it
for the price of anything did increase
what has to happen well the the demand
has to increase faster than the supply
right so let's let's look at possible
theories what what our demand drivers
that could make housing prices go higher
let me write that in green demand
drivers well maybe maybe the population
maybe population grew faster than the
housing stock
when I say the housing stock I just mean
that well we're saying just demand so
let me just say population the housing
stock is supply so population goes up
that's a demand driver what's another
demand driver incomes incomes go up
right that's another reason maybe if a
lot of people just become a lot richer
they're willing to pay for houses and
water supply what are the supply drivers
well these are just new homes built new
homes built so if you buy the the
classical supply demand argument why
housing prices increased by 40 percent
from 2000 to 2004 or why they increased
four by eighty percent from 2000 to 2006
these dynamics should have grown faster
than these dynamics so the population or
maybe the total income if you take the
population and the incomes grew faster
than the new homes built so let's let's
see if that's true
so I found this this New York Times
article and you could do some Google
searches and I'm sure you can find
probably better data this is just me
doing it very fast search on this stuff
let me see if I can get it up okay here
it is so this is from a New York Times
article this is a little graph and this
is showing this is the average of
incomes reported on all tax returns so
notice from 2000 to 2004 the average
reported actually went down it actually
went down from 2000 to 2004 and this is
interesting let me see if I can bring
this in here so here they say total
total reported income in two thousand
four dollars so they adjusted for
inflation fell 1.4% but because the
population grew during that period
average real incomes declined more than
twice as much falling by 1641 a year or
three percent so what are they saying
they're saying the total the total
income fell by 1.4 percent but the
population must have grown by about one
and a half percent and so the average
per-capita was 3% so let me let me write
that in summary so what do we know
what happened we know from 2000 to 2004
and this is nationwide 2000 to 2004 we
know that the population increased by
roughly one point by roughly 1.5 percent
so not by much I mean this is over a
four year period so per year it's it's
it was growing by less than a percent
and then if you go to the income income
per person income or actually this is
probably well this is income per for tax
filing but that's a pretty good proxy
income for tax filing that declined by
three percent so the total money
available the total money available that
New York Times article just showed us
actually declined by what did they say
by 1.4 percent so the argument that
somehow there's more money out there
chasing you know the same number of
homes or slightly larger number of homes
doesn't really doesn't really carry
carry much weight but just let's just
make sure maybe for some reasons maybe
houses were destroyed or the number of
homes built just didn't keep pace with
this population increase so let's see
what what data we can find on that well
let's see I found this this thing this
says that this was in 1999 they say the
composition of estimated 115 million
housing units the United States so we
can say roughly that in 2000 that there
were 115 million housing units so in
2000 there were 115 million housing
units so let's see over this time period
how many roughly how many housing units
were built what percentage did the
housing stock increased by and I found
this data here and this is annualized
new home builds by year and I'm not
going to go through all of the math but
if you see let's see if I go back to
2000 I know this might be hard for you
to see some but if we pick up pretty
much any any month you know from 2000
2001
this isn't thousands so on an annualized
basis maybe 1.5 million homes that's was
two thousand but it started accelerating
all the way to 2004 by 2004 we were
building roughly two million homes a
year so over that time period we can say
on average you know you can work the
numbers for you know to get an exact
number but it should work out we were
building about 1.8 million homes a year
1.8 million new homes per year new homes
per year and we can assume that that the
you know how homes destroyed were pretty
negligible I I'm not aware of most
neighborhoods where they were you know
bulldozing homes if anything they were
just renovating homes but these are
brand-new homes so over that four year
period I'm just going to focus there
because that's where we got data from
that New York Times article how many
homes were built well 1.8 times four
that's what that's a 1.8 times four so
roughly 7.2 million homes new homes were
built over that time period and we
started with the base of 115 million
roughly in 2000 divided by so over that
time period the housing stock increased
by 6% so the supply of homes went up by
6% so what's going on here from 2000 to
2004 we built a ton of houses the supply
of homes went up by 6% people's incomes
actually went down because we were in a
recession people were getting laid off
or they were just willing to work for
less income went down and the population
barely increased and if we look at the
total dollars that were being earned
that actually went down so the the
actual money out there to pay for houses
went down and at the same time the total
number of houses went up but at the same
time in over this exact same period the
prices of houses went up by 46% or I
forgot the number but it was
40-something percent and actually
continued to race up until 2000 where
2006 where it went up eighty percent
relative to 2000 so this is is is is
bizarre this is you know it's
basic economics would tell us that if
the supply is increasing if the supply
is increasing and the demand is
decreasing prices if anything should
come down so what happened so I'm going
to let you think about that a little bit
that you know there you have the supply
demand thing that would tell you the
prices went down but not only did they
not go down but they raced up faster
than they've ever done in in history in
the history of the United States so in
the next video I'm going to tell you
frankly why I'm pretty sure housing
prices did go up see you soon